Albert Brewer of the mmq be senior
writer of the m/l QE you're on the Rich
Eisen show how are you doing Albert I'm
doing fine
I'm doing fine what do you think the top
story is right now as you and I are
talking not even first blush 24 hours
into the new league year what's going on
draft everything I'll just give you that
sort of macro question to start us off
here impact transaction moving decipher
right now with the Antonio Brown player
I think it's also about our organization
and what's happened over the last two
years there and you know that was it
forever and ever
they've been a very quite a friendly
place and they've been able to own a big
personality that's why those at
battleship tomato type head coaches from
from Chuck Noll Phil counter by Tomlin
and this is really the first time that
it's blown up on them they've always
been able to sort of cast a wider net
there don't bring town in because
they've been able to handle these
personalities and got a lot of big
personalities within their walls because
of that and you know I think when you
want to look at this column macro
perspective what does this mean for the
Steelers Berra no one's ever seen the
way they do things the way they've
always been able to handle big
personality players like all that we've
never seen this boil over on that way
and so of course Eternia Browns going to
the line is a big deal you know you're a
great player so I think that there's a
bigger bigger story here and sort of
bubbling under the surface it's going to
be interesting to watch well I think
it's also a league wide if another
player is going to utilize social media
yeah to create a situation that even the
team agrees is not is not something that
could be put back together again or back
in the bottle and you know everybody
seems to think well you need to have a
nine-year Hall of Fame resume to pull
that off not only get out but get to a
team where you want to go and then get
the contract you want I mean that triple
play is something we've never seen
before and I'm wondering because again
we can fill the void with whatever we
want to fill it until we get an actual
we may never get it that that that might
have played into the Giants thinking
with Odell Beckham you know I mean I
look at ever it's like alright so we
know the way all these contracts work
right like so you know you get a four or
five year contract really over the first
two years of guarantee need but after
that that you know you kind of go into
this situation where it's year-to-year a
team option and we've seen players sort
of start to start to change their what
they're making when they get out of the
guaranteed money and that's exactly
where Antonia Brown was like this was
the turn eighteen and nineteen when the
contract became not guarantee and you
know I think in the past we've always
had situations where players could say
well you know I want to raise or give me
a bump or a little funny around I don't
know like that this lever has ever been
used as well it's like instead of going
to your own team looking for a deal like
rated he'll demand a trade and then you
know for the trade to go through say you
need to have a good contract like you
wonder if it's going to be a new level
for players requires if I can't get more
where I'm at
and I'm out of my Darren seed money well
and I need to get to a new team that's
going to be excited to have me and
that's going to pay a guaranteed money
to get me and so I think that there are
a number of players that we can watch
along those lines over the next year so
to get out of the fantasy money and the
one I'm sort of just keeping an eye on
right now at the Julio Jones in Atlanta
who you know got a renegotiation last
year with preachers Western field he's
got two years left on his contract he's
adamant guarantees and the Falcons
promise that they'd redo his deal it's
offseason if that's not to his
satisfaction could yak fur trade out of
Atlanta it's just
it creates an interesting new lever that
really hasn't been there for players Fat
Albert beer here on the Rich Eisen show
so then why was Odell traded why was the
Code Red ordered so that that's the
question right now especially since
Albert you know just to let me just keep
trying to set it up here to get it all
out I mean they residing last year and
gentlemen did say at the combine in a
reasonable statement one would think we
didn't Reese on him to trade him
so clearly they thought whatever they
discussed with Pat Shermer between
player and coach new coach and ownership
they clearly thought that that change
would bring about a change and then
something clearly happened in the last
16 game regular season schedule or
before it or after it that caused the
Giants to say we're done here so what
happened
I think organizationally they took a
hard left turn in the middle of the
season and it was subtle and it sort of
flew under the radar but if you want to
go back to the October meetings and the
Giants are really struggling and John
Mayer said publicly we need to take a
hard look at this and we may not be
doing it overnight and I think what has
been the case in New York for the last
five six years that roster was broken
and they were able in 2016 to band-aid
it and they go out they sign Olivia
Vernon and Jinora shank use of snacks
Harrison and then they make the playoffs
in season one everything went right
right and then the two off seasons after
that they were teasing that success like
they felt like they were a lot closer
than they actually work I think in the
middle of last season what happened
organizationally was the people that
building came to the realization we're
not as close as we think we are we
cannot be operating like a wind now
organization because that's not where we
are and I think that they were late on
that they certainly should have realized
that earlier but I do think in the
middle of the season they came to that
realization but they need a full on
rebuild and so I don't think we can
relate anything they do now anything
that they did before November or
November and I think now they're going
through a full rebuild and the question
becomes is it worth having a great great
great player but a guy who's a wide
receiver who can be a pain in the ass
around when you're looking to rebuild
maybe bring a young quarterback in
you're gonna be trying to fill your
building but talented young guys or do
you go and flip them for some capital so
you've gotten you've done a little bit
more to rebuild your team with and so I
know a lot of people are trying to just
oppose and it's against the moves the
Giants take the loss to us
I don't do that because I've my feeling
on it is there was an understanding that
was arrived at in the middle of the
season and there now as a result of that
going into a full week so then if you're
in a full rebuild then then you can't
you can't start your two-time Super Bowl
winning franchise face future
hall-of-famer certainly ring a halt you
know hall-of-famer locally we can have
an argument about Eli in the actual Hall
that makes no sense then I mean so so
the court you even mentioned bringing a
young quarterback and I assume it's
gonna be tween Haskins from from your
alma mater or it could be a surprise in
calamari we could hit that in a second
but right the question for me is what do
they Eli's gonna get a bonus just for
being on the team on Saturday this is
this is it this is they gotta make this
whole thing now don't they I think you
have to look at it though you have to
look at Eli Manning now is the first
quarterback I know that sounds weird
because of all the history he has there
and you know it's tough but something to
look at a guy like that who's got that
many helps in the wall as a bridge
quarterback but right now I that's
that's how you have to look at him he's
a bridge to the next guy he's making 17
million this year that's only 1 million
dollars more the Tyrod Taylor made it
the birch died in Cleveland last year so
you're already paying about what the
going rate Berbers quarterback is and
you know you know what you're getting
instead of going out and spending on
line and a hill or someone like that or
or nick foles you've got someone in the
building who you know you understand
what he's about and you hope that
playing him having him in the building
will get you to the next guy whether
it's this year or next I mean that's the
best way I can explain it she's just I
mean I and I think that the Dolphins is
sort of struggle with this a little bit
was Tannehill to it's like can you turn
a guy who was your franchise quarterback
into the bridge quarterback because it
logistically makes more sense they're
going and doing what Cleveland did last
year and spending 16 million dollars on
tie-rod or what Arizona did going and
spending 20 million on st. Bradford
few more minutes left here with Albert
brear so then then comes the Tyler Marie
drafted first overall do you believe
that's the case right now I was gonna
live but I was just right now that
Arizona will take them number one I look
I think you have if you're if you're
Mike Bidwell or speak on you have to be
a hundred percent behind Kliff Kingsbury
you took an enormous swing in hiring a
guy who you know just got fired out of
big 12 and I think he's a good
quarterback guy and a a good offensive
folks but no matter how you slice that
it's a big swing and if you're gonna be
if you're gonna take a big swing then
you have to be behind the guy and if the
guy comes to you and says this kind of
Murray this is a guy who can make my
offense fly you have to listen to him
and I think that hasn't happened already
at some point it will just based on what
I know about relationships there in the
big 12 I talk to Lincoln Riley about
this a couple of weeks ago and he played
with course Kingsbury Texas Tech they're
from the same offensive family he
coached against Kingsbury the last four
years in the big 12 and Lincoln Riley
told me that Kyle armor is an absolutely
perfect fit for a personality sampling
scheme standpoint everything for Kliff
Kingsbury and so I can't tell you that I
know the Kliff Kingsbury loves Cuyler
Murray and what kind of learner on the
office but right now based on what I do
know I can tell you that I do think that
that's the case and that in my mind Kyle
Murray the favorites the first overall
that well if that happens then don't you
think they need to trade rosin sooner
rather than later because they have a
better market for him if they do it on
the Qt as opposed to drafting the guy
and everybody knows they've got to get
rid of Josh Rosen and then suddenly they
don't get their market value for him so
walk me through how that all plays out
who would be in the market for rosin and
and would the giants be one of those
teams to bring this whole thing full
circle it's tricky it's definitely
tricky you know because it's like so
many you put roses on the market you're
telling everybody along with the first
day you know what I mean so like you
have to be sure of what you're gonna do
because then you know alright now we've
kind of declared what our intentions are
I think the mark
for loading to be really interesting for
teams that are looking for the next guy
now you mentioned Giants Miami they're
so obvious once the Redskins that I
think would investigate it to me they're
really interesting teams so it would be
the ones that have gotten older
quarterbacks that aren't going to be bad
enough in the near future to draft the
next one and I'm talking about teams
like Green Bay New Orleans the Chargers
the Patriots the Saints you know those
teams if you're one of those teams and
you're looking at it you're sitting how
am I ever going to be in position to
draft the successor to Drew Brees or
Phillip Rivers or Tom Brady when we're
in the playoffs every year well you have
to get creative and going and getting a
Josh Rosen will be a creative way to
attack you where in the short term
you've got a guy at 2 million per for
the next three years so guys we get to
backup for you and so that's like the
low end potential for the trade the high
end is that you get your answer for the
next 10 or 15 years so it makes all the
sense in the world to be that one of
those teams would look at it and I mean
look at the Los Angeles chargers rich I
mean if you're them bringing Josh Rosen
home is it worth looking the 28th
overall pick for him and saying okay
we'll bring him in he'll be a good desk
piece here in the short term and there's
long term we may actually have a
successor for Phillip Rivers and visit
team remember those having and you're
right they're having trouble selling
itself in Los Angeles right now all of a
sudden maybe they've got a face of the
franchise there's a local kid for the
next 15 years and is a big piece of what
if right there from Albert prayer last
one for you Albert the levy on bail
contract under you've been crunching the
numbers did he come close to making the
money back that he left on the table
last year to make his point and win his
freedom the way he did
no I mean I think they liked me fine
financially now the deal is not a
horrible one but he certainly left more
money on the table and there's no
question about that on every single
level after one year after two years
after 30 years he said it was really
just about dollars and cents you're
taking the Steelers off for last year
and you know they made a mistake they
they they bet on themselves and they
thought they were going to be able to
get more than Todd Gurley
but they'll come out since he's more
than our running back he should be pays
like I and wide receiver that clearly
didn't happen here
and you know the market just wasn't
there and I you know if you want to go
back and look at why and there's a
hundred reasons why he said adage that's
part of the equation
you've got injury history that
especially history the the position he
plays obviously has then the value to
some degree over the last twenty years
you know it's just there's a myriad of
reasons why this went down the way it
went down but I don't think there's any
rational argument you can make if it's
just about the finances and not about
praying for Mike Tomlin or playing in
Pittsburgh where's playing in New York
sounds there's any way you can make an
argument that he came out on top at this
one our thanks to the call as always
enjoy a chat we'll chat next month as or
at the end of the month as we get close
to the draft yeah you bet that's albert
prayer check out his work the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience